not only did Ariana Dubose do the thing
at the 2023 vafta Awards she rehearsed
the thing too
my woman King on Wednesday Broadway
music director Benjamin raula shared
this clip of Ariana on Tick Tock
rehearsing her now viral opening number
from Sunday's award show while getting
her makeup done
genius and Jamie Lee you are all of us
he captioned the clip with the phrase we
can't get enough of backstage with
Ariana getting ready to do the thing
Viola Davis my woman King he also said
it was an honor to give love to all of
these iconic women and get the party
started
Viola Davis
and Jamie Lee who are all of us
following her performance of are doing
it for themselves We are family and that
original wrap people weighed in online
with some not so nice critiques and
Ariana deactivated her Twitter account
one of the events producers Nick Bolin
came to the Oscar winners defense
calling the backlash incredibly unfair
pointing out that it was a great year
for women in film and they wanted to
celebrate that look at you you're just
literally the embodiment of like female
empowerment thank you I appreciate it I
mean that's what we got to do out here
since then the internet has been flooded
with memes like this one shared by pop
culture commentator Evan Ross Katz and
Ariana she loved it sliding into the
comments to give it her approval she
also shared this clip of the New York
City gay men's chorus putting their own
spin on her song writing yes Gents
[Music]
honestly who hasn't been singing that
song since Sunday
you're a genius
as for Ariana she's in on the joke guys
Benjamin wants us to know she's been
giggling at everyone who has the campy
little number stuck in their head
Viola Davis my woman King Adventure okay
you're a genius and Jamie Lee you are
all of us one of us is here alone all
these boys we need a bigger throws up
after the life is strong be true to you
you can't go wrong